okay now what does this look like
if i put them all together right what
i've got
is there's zero and where are my other
important jobs
fifth and third
okay yeah question um with this question
um
why don't you take zero's case like
normally
absolutely okay i have to take it as a
case because in each case to
simplify out and solve i have to
multiply by x
right so multiplying by x means you've
got to consider whether it's
positive or negative okay so you can see
what happens here
is quite different to what happens here
even though the mechanics are
the same the negative makes the
inequality
shift around fine
because x is negative okay so in this
case x is negative
that's what makes this case important if
you have an equation which says three is
greater than
two and you multiply by minus one minus
three is not
greater than minus three so the x
are you questioning this step for like
is it from here to here
yeah yeah okay so when i multiply
through that the difference from this
line to this line
is two things number one i just expanded
this so expansions are fun
okay but when i multiply through by x
you have to think okay what kind of
number is x i have said at the very
beginning
x is negative and when you multiply by
negative numbers like minus one
the inequality switches
um directions it's not changing the
the value of this variable it's changing
the direction of the inequality
okay imagine if you have a number line
and then x can be any number on the
number line
x can be a negative number so if without
a negative sign
you know why you bring case to a case
yeah aren't you saying that x cannot be
equal just said
you can you put lessons okay
you know you only have case one and case
two causes absolute value right
no right case two and case three
come from the absolute value because the
junction for the absolute value is a
third value right yep
if i had no absolute value i'd i have
still two cases
i'd have x is less than zero x is
greater
yeah you gotta
okay now what i'm gonna do is stop
answering your questions about cases and
give you a subtle hint
that this is why i might not like this
method
okay but i'm just going to keep going
okay
yeah i'm very subtle okay let me finish
answering this right
i'm taking everything together i've got
x is less than zero so that's
that way okay i've got between a fifth
and a third so that's
here okay and then i've got uh a third
to
one sorry i forgot that point okay now
you might have noticed
okay that's weird i've got a hole there
is that really a hole okay
the reason and the answer is no it's not
but i can't just say no it's not
like why is it not well i have to test x
equals that third wait why is that not
quite say it again why is it not
included
as a whole it's not it's monohull
because it works
so if you test out x equals a third so
it's a random
perception it's not random it has to do
with the junction you get from this
function okay so it's indeterminate
it's indeterminate
once you before you test it but isn't
the original thing like
the less than sign or for a less than or
equal to well watch what happens
let's let's test out x equals the third
because it sure looks like
okay one fifth check yep yep yep yep no
and then it just keeps on why is that
well let's find out okay
so how do you test you just take your
value and you pop it in the left hand
side
let's do it okay so absolute value of
three times a third
minus one close your absolute value all
over
a third okay so
what's that that's zero over a third
right and that's zero and zero is less
than two
so a third satisfies
the inequality okay
is your question about cases because if
it is i'm not gonna answer
no it was about the one-third i'm gonna
keep going
okay if you do it by cases this is the
way it works
okay yeah if we have to test that point
does that mean we have to test all the
other points
no you don't because the way that i got
those inequalities like where does this
effect come from
it comes from my algebra it comes from
me solving it okay
and the same with the one and the same
with the zero okay
but the one-third doesn't come from
algebra it comes from something i
introduced namely
the cases i haven't even neither of
these accounts for
like greater than it's not inclusive you
solve the problem by doing that in one
of the cases having a greater need
okay now then you start to ask the
question
well which case do you put it on okay do
you put in this one
okay so i i'm gonna no i'm not gonna do
it
all right i'm gonna shut the door sorry
if it's completely irrelevant you can
ask me that
you can ask it because i'm going to run
out of time i'm seriously going around